hello people of podcast land welcome
back my guest today is none other than
Derek Siver's writer entrepreneur
programmer fascinating human he is one
of the best guests I've ever heard on
tim ferrissí show so I'm very fortunate
to have got ahold of him and sit him
down on the big stage obviously modern
wisdom so yeah had a long list of
questions to go through today including
what have you been working on recently
get to find out where Derek's been
spending his time when are you going to
finally release the now three books that
he's been sat on excellence in life and
how he perceives it why nuance is where
truth lies rather than in as simple and
succinct answer values and how they can
both guide and restrict the way that we
operate why it doesn't matter that we
only live for a short period of time and
in 50 years no one may even remember our
names oh it was so good Derek man thank
you so much for coming on it was
phenomenal
I already want to do another one in
other news if you are new here don't
forget to hit the subscribe button you
will receive one episode every Monday
and every Thursday with the world's most
fascinating humans delivered directly to
your listening device of choice but for
now please welcome the wise and
wonderful Derek Siver's
[Music]
Derek Siver's in the building how are
you man
any particular building will do yes I am
in a building you are in the building
you're in our building today that's true
I mean you're our audio building thank
you for having me to your audio home
thank you very much for joining us so as
a man who says no to a lot very glad
that he said yes to coming on this
podcast it's been a while since I've
heard you put out an audio podcast I'm
very honored to be the guy that we've
re-entered 2012 with well it's a 2012
Adam 12 2020 you can see it's been a
long day uh yeah I really really like
what you're doing with modern wisdom and
I really like your topics of
conversations so these days when
somebody asks me to do an interview you
know I've got nothing I'm promoting or
pitching so it's all about the quality
of conversation and you sent me some
really interesting topics of
conversation thank you yeah it's um
there's two two types of guests I found
during the podcast one guests who do the
due diligence and then jump in and then
there's another type who like to really
go deep
before we begin about what we're gonna
be talking about and both of them I find
to have their have their merits but yeah
it's I'm really looking forward to today
to the the listeners I've been going
back with Derek since November time
before I went to Bali before I went to
Greece and I've been thinking about all
of these different questions so we've
we've got a big breadcrumb trail of
stuff that we've been thinking about but
the first question that I've got for you
is what have you been working on
recently if you were to update your now
page today what is say
ah I have been programming um up until
Christmas
I was working maniacally on my next book
which is called how to live which I'm so
[ __ ] excited about and I was
seriously doing like 15 hour days of
writing which I think you're not
supposed to do for health reasons but I
would just get out of bed at 6 a.m. and
I would just write and write and write
and write and write you know had stopped
for lunch and I just write until I would
drop at midnight and I was doing that
for months on end and I was so into it
but then around Christmastime
my assistant reminded me that some other
things having to do with my first and
second book are on hold because they're
waiting for me to program some things
for the translators and the store so
ever since Christmas I paused I said
what would it be now March something so
two and a half months for two and a half
months I've been doing nothing but
programming every day probably again
programming the the store where I'm
gonna sell the books directly from my
site programming a translation system to
manage all the translations of my books
and stuff like that I've just been in
programmer head which is one that's cool
I am I had Stephen Wolfram on the
podcast awhile ago you know Stephen I
met him when he was a teenager and I was
a little kid I
my dad's a particle physicist we were
living here in Abington England and
Stephen Wolfram my dad tells me I don't
remember this but when I was five I had
dinner with Stephen um haven't seen him
since then you should reach out to him
Stephen for the people for the people
who don't know who he is go back and
listen to the episode just search
Stephen Wolfram in the modern wisdom
page but that is a man who has really
really optimized the ability to code as
much as possible you know he's got a
special laptop harness where he can go
for a walk while he's still while he's
still coding which just looks like the
maddest thing you got this guy with
essentially a baby stroller attached to
him but instead of it being a child this
is just like some Python or some wolfram
mathematica or
from hunger whatever it is but you know
I did a five-day long walk in the
forests of New Zealand and I had so many
thoughts during that time I for one I
just enjoyed it so much just walking
walking walking through a gorgeous
forest felt like yeah this is how life
should be like if you can get away with
it this is a great way to live to spend
most of your time walking through a
gorgeous forest and I but then I have
other aspirations in life
you know I there's a lot of things I
want to write and there things I want to
read so reading while walking I think
we've solved that pretty well with
audiobooks but writing while walking in
I can't do that yet I'd like to that
would be maybe like a skill that one
could practice you know the way that you
decide like okay I'm gonna start
speaking Portuguese or you know learning
to play the sitar you would start at the
very beginning and you would understand
that you're not expected to know how to
do this thing today but yeah something
like this idea of writing through voice
and like recording your voice instead of
having to write down visually you know
and typewriter and see it in front of
you that would be just a very different
skill to to learn but it seems like it'd
be really useful like I think we have
between the voice recording and voice
recognition dictation software I think
we have the tools where it'd be really
really viable to do this as your main
method of writing is to just do it
orally um it's very appealing um how
much of it is the being outside and how
much of is it is the movement because
you could get you could quite easily get
a treadmill desk you could get a true
runner desk which is one of those sounds
powered yeah I think it's it's the
combination it's a bucket because I mean
you could also say if it was just the
outside you could say okay we'll set up
your laptop on a picnic bench outside so
now I think it's it's the bullets it's
the walking outside too
forced cut I've never I think I've tried
to treadmill once in my life and it just
felt like the saddest thing and we we
use them as a as a negative metaphor
don't we like you know how's work it's
just you know the treadmill yeah you are
right it's badly branded they should
rebrand so that's what you've been
working on recently you've been
programming and writing am i right in
thinking that your how to live book is
that a descendant of the directives that
you wrote yes child
the love child of the directives yes and
if you have read the book by David
Eagleman called some s um it's it's an
homage to that book some is probably my
single favorite book if there's a page
on my website where I collect my notes
from every book I've read since 2007
it's silver stork slash book and I think
there's 300 something books there now
that I've read and so I take detailed
notes whenever I'm reading something and
so some is the number one book at the
top of that list because I have it
sorted with my top recommendations up
top and I wish everybody would read that
book I just think it's one of the most
brilliant creative think piece books
it's it's like 40 little short stories
just two to three pages long each each
one answering the question what happens
when you die
and so it's it's it's a recent
reimagining so it's 40 different answers
to that one question okay and I just
love that format so much where you know
chapter 3 will say when you die you're
you know you awaken in the Great Hall
it's just empty and you find out that
God is a creator he's not a manager you
know he tipped over the first domino
billions of years ago and he's on to
other things he doesn't even know we
exist
you know chapter 6 when you die you find
out that what you knew as your life was
actually just an artificial intelligence
program you are an artificial
intelligence program and so I just like
this this idea of 40 answers to one
question each one two
really disagreeing with the previous
chapter because it's just a reimagining
of the different answer and so my book
how to live is an homage to some it's
using that exact same format to answer
the question how to live it seems like
your approach to writing your approach
to content production in general at the
moment based on if anyone goes to civets
dog you can see it's lean is how I get
describe it
that's a diplomatic way of putting it
it's lean right there's there's very
very little fluff and the directives
that you came up with I think her list
of 120 essentially instructions we have
a series on this podcast called life
hacks and that is essentially directives
for Gen X who have an iPhone in the
pocket and probably thirty quid to spend
and yeah it's it's seems to be very very
lean very no fluff I wonder if that's
something that you've developed recently
or whether that's something that you've
always liked to do what you've always
liked it kind of remove the fluff hmm if
you when people come visit my house I'm
living here in Oxford now when they come
to my house the first question most
people who come in ask is do you live
here because it's just empty yeah to me
I feel quite settled I mean look I have
a couch that's that's kind of big for me
you know a couch so yeah I think the
minimalism goes through all aspects of
my life but when it comes to writing I
think it's just considerate I think the
more you say the less people hear or the
more they kind of tune out if somebody
if you tell somebody check out this
article and they click the link and they
see the article and they say okay this
is like 50 paragraphs or 100 like this
is going to take me half an hour to read
they may skim it quickly on the other
hand if they click and it's only eight
teen sentences well then hopefully
they're going to read all eight teen
sentences so I found out that the
average length of one of the articles on
my site and therefore the chapters in my
book the average length is just 22
sentences so I really you know I chisel
them down I get rid of every single word
and sentence that isn't absolutely
necessary but I think that also comes
from the fact that I spent the 15
formative years of my life as a
songwriter from the age of 14 to 29 my
primary goal in life was to be a great
songwriter and I wrote over a hundred
songs and you know that's 15 years of my
life trying to say what I want to say in
six syllables to match the melody you
know so maybe it's just like I spent so
many years you know choosing the exact
words in the minimum syllables to match
the melody so I think I still kind of
take that approach to my writing I
understand yeah it's um there's a
wonderful article by Scott Adams it's
the day you became a better writer and I
think it's probably two paragraphs long
and it's one of the most it's one of the
most cited bits of advice for fledgling
writers and Tim Ferriss quoted it on a
podcaster a while ago and essentially
broke the internet with it you just just
annihilated poor Scott site and Scott's
got a bi extra server space and so for
all this practice so moving on to some
of the things that I wanted to talk
about today so something I've been
thinking about a lot recently is to do
with crossroad opportunities in life so
we have these kind of like epochs in our
life right we have these grooves that
we've greased and then often that comes
a time where we need to choose whether
or not we continue to grease that groove
or we decide to take ourselves outside
of that and often like a river we take
the path of least resistance hmm but to
change the flow of that River there's a
lot of inertia to get over a lot of
stagnation to get over I wanted to know
your thoughts about that
opportunities in life um well I think
when were at those times in life where
we're making decisions we forget to
explicitly name the benefit of doing
nothing of just continuing as we are now
right like too many people they say okay
I have to I have to make a choice
between a and B but then they forget
well there's option C which is to just
do nothing um and just carry on as you
are now so I don't mean consider it I
mean actually state it and say it out
loud like name it as an option so the
usual thing you know people say should I
do this new thing what are the benefits
what are the drawbacks so I think that
you should also ask what are the
benefits of not doing this new thing
like what are the benefits of doing
nothing um I really like this I heard
this idea in a book called um the
courage to be disliked which was also
really probably one of the best things
I've ever read and it tells you to
consider why you're not changing like
why are you just continuing on the way
you are it is clearly offering you a
benefit if you keep doing it so if you
ask yourself why am I just carrying on
as usual you might come up with an
answer like well my life is pretty good
now I'm happy or there's a chance that
doing this new thing would make my life
harder and I don't want to risk that um
so you can name the mental mindset ones
right like my life feels under control
right now and I like feeling in control
I like feeling like an expert I like
feeling smart if I do this new thing I'm
going to feel dumb and out of control
like trying to write a book while
walking through the forest um but then I
think that once you bring these to the
surface then instead of sitting in your
subconscious you you've now brought them
to the table alright like you can now
weigh them in your decision you've laid
them out as an alternate option
and then you have to admit that it's
okay to do nothing like I think often we
we feel that we're always supposed to be
doing something but you know Warren
Buffett is quite public but he has a
quiet partner Charlie Munger who's a
really interesting sinker Charlie Munger
gave this interesting advice to young
investors so people of course you know
saying everybody just you know gets him
up on a stage and says how can we be
successful investors so when it was top
bits of advice he gave specifically to
young people I think it was a speech he
gave at a college graduation was he said
imagine you've got one of those little
loyalty punch cards you know one of
those little loyalty cards with ten
holes in it that they can punch out yes
he said imagine it's got ten holes in it
that can be punched and that is the
total number of investments you're
allowed to make in your life that's it
you can only make ten investments in
your life and he said if that was the
case you'd be better off just waiting
and waiting for years for the right
thing to come by and then when the right
thing comes along you you'd knock it out
of the park
to use the baseball metaphor you just
dive in all the way when you see the
right opportunity um which is kind of
what my next book called hell yeah or no
is about I want you to talk about your
approach to decision-making in general
and you have a page on your site which
is slash slow right
I think that's yeah they considered
again the same way that the articles are
lean the decision-making is considered
is that because of Charlie's approach
that if you make the right decision you
only need to get a couple of them very
very right there's a theme
is gonna come up a few times in this
conversation which is there's no right
or wrong approach all of these things
this you know this modern wisdom these
philosophies are just tools that we use
for specific situations so I have this
article called hell yeah or no that a
lot of people quote and they tell me
that they they like that idea of hell
yeah or no and so that you email me
saying oh this is great I'm gonna use it
I'm using it for everything in my life
now they say no no no no no no no Haley
Arno is like one specific tool for one
specific situation when you're
overwhelmed with options and you're in
danger of drowning well then you raise
the bar all the way and say no to almost
everything and say yes to almost nothing
but it's for a situation where you know
you're in danger of drowning if for
example you're straight out of college
and you welcome to the world and you're
about to jump out there and try to make
something of yourself then it's probably
a better strategy to say yes to
everything just do it all sleepless say
yes to everything try everything go
everywhere meet everyone
do you know 20 different jobs per year
for a few weeks each and just do it all
and then when something hits when the
world starts rewarding you in a certain
aspect well then you can double down on
that and then when you start to get
successful in that one thing and then
everybody wants a piece of you well then
now maybe it's a time to start saying no
to almost everything and just stay
focused on this one thing that is like
giving you major payoffs so when you ask
about my slow thinking that was more of
just like that felt like a
a cathartic admission um also probably a
little bit of a disclaimer yes thank you
good word yes it was a bit of a
disclaimer
um because partially because I meet
strangers that asked me deep questions
and they go oh Derek Siver's oh my god
I'm gonna ask you something they asked
me a question and I say huh
I don't know just look at me a little
disappointed I thought you're supposed
to have the answer I'm like well in a
few days I will so I just noticed that
I'm just not the quickest draw but
that's okay it was just I just spent a
little time thinking that through and
realizing I don't I don't need to be
quick and in fact I think it's really
kind of cool not to try to be quick
because when when you try to be quick
you know you think oh my god I have to
answer in two seconds you know like
would say game jeopardy where do you
have to press the buzzer quickly you
just give this kind of knee-jerk
reaction off the top of your head you
get the first thing that comes to mind
and I've just found that the first thing
that comes to mind isn't as interesting
as the the things that come to mind much
later whether it's five minutes or five
days later but it's those things that
once you work through the usual reaction
and get to the other side of that that's
this should I want to you know dive into
so yeah it was kind of embracing my slow
approach I agree I think certainly
there's there's something to do with
closing the loop as well we all want to
appear competent capable you asked me a
question oh yeah of course I've got you
know I've already written an article on
that don't you worry man like let me
just pull out the bibliography and I'll
start citing from all the different
books because it makes me look really
cool great I I fall into that trap I'm
watching myself now I'm trying to
constantly strip away the very sticky
elements of the persona of now becoming
a
competent regular podcaster so when
people ask me things oh well you know I
had this conversation with Aubrey Marcus
it's very interesting on episode 117
when he said that's like no no no Chris
that's a [ __ ] sake mate like just you
know just allow yourself to sit with the
question
don't try and broadcast this this value
of U which is competent and capable and
this than the other because I don't
think that's me and for some people that
might be you know you may be the Gary
Vaynerchuk of this world perhaps right
someone who's one of these hyper quick
thinkers who does the Q&A on stage and
you know the big conference thing and
you know the life advice I'm not I'm not
convinced that that's where my value
lies and it would appear that you have
identified in yourself that you add more
value by waiting and considering and
then coming back then giving something
to close the loop and and look cool and
look capable and competent right but it
isn't just about looks
um in my case I am pursuing the path of
being a great writer thinker kind of guy
I'm not pursuing the path of being a
great interviewer or you know debater
yep if I wanted to be a great
interviewer or debater then I would have
to change my value system accordingly I
would say okay well I used to be a slow
thinker and that's my default but I need
to practice being a quick thinker now
because I really want to be a great
debater or interviewer and that just you
need to be quick that's just that how
that game goes at home Niro approach
right so yeah the slow thinking is for
me for my current situation I get it and
it facilitates that so you've touched on
one of the words I want you to move onto
there which is values what would you
identify as your life values it's a
question that I like to ask and it's one
that I've been pondering a lot recently
and I managed to well why do I tell you
mine should I tell you my okay please
thank you of course I didn't access
at the start of the year and I refined
mine down to five you supposed to have
no more than five I mean who's who's
that the master of values told us that
you're not suppose the values agency
told me I wasn't loved at more than five
values or else I'd have to pay tax on
the remember and the ones over the top
so mine actually spelled out words they
spot that an acronym cases so number one
curiosity to be curious to learn new
things about myself in the world around
me a adventure to experience new things
and meet and see new people a word I
made up which was selfless development
which is to learn about myself improve
and then teach others what I've learned
II was excellence to be precise with my
thoughts words and actions I want to
fulfill my potential I want to make the
most of minutes and then the final one
was self care if I don't look after
myself I can't do the things that I want
to do for myself and others and I
realized that at the moment if I ensure
that broadly most of the stuff that I do
on a daily basis meets some of those
most of those at least one of those I'm
probably in the right ballpark well very
cool thank you okay well I think my big
ones are they're not single words like
that but they're more like a concept so
to me one of the biggest ones is to
ignore what you say but notice what you
do so I think about this one a lot that
um that the words your actions reveal
your values so it kind of doesn't matter
what you say your your actions show what
you really value you can say that you
you think it's important to be kind to
everybody but then if you're going
around being an [ __ ] well then that's
clearly not one of your values no matter
what you say so I think that we do too
much thinking about what we want in
theory and too little noticing what we
want in practice so that's kind of the
same thing right like we we can say we
can think that we want something but
you really have to go out into the world
and try things so if you have a theory
about what you want you have to go try
it as soon as possible to find out if
you really want that and then be very
open to the fact that your theory might
have been wrong and don't be upset about
that you just say oh okay you just
especially once you acknowledge the
difference you can say okay well sitting
at home in my bedroom with my notebook I
thought I wanted this thing but now that
I'm actually doing it I found out I
don't and that's okay so another value
or yeah I think we often oversimplify
like you think I'm sick of the city I
want to live in the country so you move
to the country but then after a few
months you miss the city so the true and
I haven't a lot of friends in New York
City that did this New York City is one
of those places where it has this really
nice upstate New York area it's like
just an hour north of New York City and
so a lot of people feel like burnt out
in the city so they say you know what I
need to move upstate and then they do
but then after a few months almost every
time they missed the city so I think the
truth was more nuanced which is that
sometimes you prefer the city and
sometimes you prefer the country but
that nuanced truth is less dramatic it's
less simple so it's harder to you know
tweet your stance on that like we kind
of I think we we want to have a very
simple version of our self-identity so
that we can fit it into our little
social profile and say who we are
quickly in a sentence but and I think we
often oversimplify um or mmm sorry the
thing that we said a couple minutes ago
where often things are situational like
you want one thing when you're in a
certain situation but not when you're
not right like I said the hell yeah or
no is an idea for a certain situation
but then the problem is we feel some
need to decide like well which is it do
I value this thing or not so I think
often about its kind of rule of thumb
but don't oversimplify that you need to
acknowledge nuance
and acknowledge conditional situations
yeah friends of mine that when my
friends and I like my friends are kind
of spread out around the world so most
of our conversations are by phone and
when friends have these kind of life
situations I hear they're often trying
to decide am I going to do this thing or
that thing or do I prefer this or that
and I'm always the one that I feel it's
like my job to remind them to
acknowledge nuance that nuance that the
answer might be both I like this idea
that in between black and white is not
only gray but actually every color in
the world so I think you can choose to
be colorful in your values and like
colors in nature you can also
acknowledge that your ever changing you
know like I've gone through some very
distinct phases in my life where I've
made a life decision to be in the middle
of everything you know I'm gonna move to
Singapore to be in the middle of Asia
I'm gonna meet everybody you do
everything and I did that for a few
years and then I had a kid then I was
like hmm
I've got a baby now I want to move to
the middle of nowhere in New Zealand and
just raise my kid in nature and you know
give the finger to the world so this is
like go buy world I'm gonna raise a kid
for you I just like I just disappeared
off to New Zealand for seven years and
had that phase and now just this past
year I moved here to well that's gonna
say I moved to Europe you know I moved
to England a little island off the coast
of Europe but um I'm kind of you know
I'm next to Europe I'm kind of in Europe
but yeah this was this decision - it was
a new phase for me - to explore more and
you know so yeah you couldn't
acknowledge that you were that what you
wanted five years ago is not what you
want now and just because you said it in
the past doesn't mean that you need to
still honor it I think a lot of people
do that thing where you know there's
this question um I've heard asked around
like what would your teenage self think
of you now and the funny thing is that's
that
that that question implies some kind of
authenticity like as if the your teenage
self was your real authentic self and
you now encumbered pure version of your
spirit that action right settled by all
of the crap that you've done over the
last 20 years or whatever yeah I get it
right but you know I think that no no no
like I in fact I think it would be
pretty sad if I was still living some
kind of life to please my teenage self
you know that would just be like that
would kind of acknowledge that I haven't
changed but man I've changed a lot I've
changed so much yeah that me now is very
different from the me from 10 years ago
and very very very different from the me
from 30 years ago and I love that
there's some bit some parts of me as
well at 17 there was some bits of me
does just a dick this really loops back
to the crossroad opportunities in life
right well we're talking about we have
this momentum which we've built up we're
moving in a direction like a river
cutting through rock and there's this
continuity bias I am a musician writer a
podcaster club promoter DJ whatever I am
that thing and does this there's this
requirement this feeling like like I was
the new thing I didn't do the do about
the new thing like if that's right if I
change that I'm not I'm not that thing
anymore that is me that was me that's
where I get my quantifiable metrics of
status and success from the people
around me this is what society is put me
on a pedestal for I've had some form of
success with this if I do this new thing
what if it all goes to pot you know it
doesn't surprise me that all of us
sometimes find it challenging to let go
of the tether to that balloon well let's
think about that question we've asked
about what are you optimizing your life
for about the difference between
existing with an understanding of your
values your goals you plan versus just
allowing life to you know blow your blow
your leaf around like what's that you
know it was that Forrest Gump where that
leaf was like that was like the
intro to Forrest Gump or the little leaf
blowing in the wind but I thought about
this with there can be reasons at stages
in your life to make yourself stick with
one thing even if you kind of want to
chase every distraction and none of the
other times there can be times where
it's just it's the right time for you to
go change distraction so I think about
this wonderful rule of thumb of asking
yourself what you want now versus what
you want most and I love that that the
simplicity of that sentence what you
want now well it's I think of shallow
happy versus deep happy right like
shallow happy is just having the I
scream deep happy is being proud of
yourself for not having the ice cream
right but most importantly it's it comes
back to whatever works for you right
like there is no philosophy or approach
to life that is inherently right or
wrong you just have to try it and see if
it works for you or not
like I don't mind holding some beliefs
that are completely false if holding
that belief works for me right now if it
gets the desired action for me so you
have to ask yourself well what does
works for you mean right like what makes
you take action what makes you take the
right actions but maybe for you for now
at this stage in your life maybe the
right action for you is to stay focused
or maybe the right action for you at
this stage in your life is to open your
mind to new inputs and to try new things
and to Adal jerry curiosity like only
you know what stage in your life you're
in like do you need to keep focusing
right now for your current desires in
life or is it time for you to stop doing
the thing you've been doing you know no
podcast is going to tell you the right
answer but I think that what these
conversations what these podcasts or
even articles and books and whatever
inputs we get in the world
are useful for hearing other people's
thoughts it's useful to help you
consider another way of being but
ultimately you need to try it on and see
if it works for you in fact not just in
theory it's interesting as I as I
produce more content on this podcast I
feel myself playing between the
prescriptive model of life you know we
class say we have Scylla we have this
life hacks series and by no means is
that something to live your life by it's
like how to make the best toasted
sandwich in a Breville sandwich maker
and stuff like well you know it's not
it's not game-changing stuff although
they take pretty good sandwiches you
know I see that side I see the
prescriptive side you know the more the
best sleeping posture how you can scale
your business using Google AdWords in
blah blah you know I see that side but
then this nuance is for me where all of
the interest is that's why that's why I
really enjoy sinking my teeth into and I
think you arrive at a solution which is
perfectly curated for you because we are
all world experts in us right we were a
world expert in derek zippers and i'm a
world expert in chris williamson so
really there isn't anyone who's is
qualified to make a decision about what
you should do than you right yeah it's
yeah taking in the inputs of others but
ya hear it all take it all in but yeah
ultimately only you know it's best yes
so this leads us on to another point I
want to bring up nicely which is
mortality and playing the game of life
so we have very fleeting time and our
existence doesn't last it doesn't mean
much after 50 years time very few people
will remember that we were there or that
care that we're gone how does this
impact the way that we should view our
lives and our occurrences within them
I have a very tiny answer but then I'm
curious to ask why you're asking because
I just never understood people's need
for meaning all right like I just tend
to go from desire to desire from
interest to interest from project to
project like I'm I'm always always
always always working towards something
so that is my meaning in life at any
given moment like even if i zoom out if
you were to say now Darren but what's
the big picture I then there's a project
or a path there to I can say okay well
in the bigger picture I want to you know
find interesting thoughts that others
haven't considered and share those with
the world you could say okay well what's
the bigger picture to that I'd say okay
well I it honestly just tickles my brain
and is viscerally pleasurable to find a
new way of looking at things and it's
creative and inventive and fun then you
could say yes but what's the real point
of that it keeps going you'd say well
then I'm I'm growing I feel that it's
like I'm constantly growing and changing
this and that and it's it's learning
more about the world I'm understanding
the world better which makes me happy on
a day to day basis the world becomes my
playground like at any point you could
zoom in and say why are you doing this
thing this minute this hour or zoom out
and say why are you doing this thing
this decade and it always has a purpose
so I don't really understand this mind
or this kind of this question of saying
yes but what's the meaning of life and
it won't even matter in a hundred years
I don't care like I you know the ant
thing of the UM what are those Tibetan
monks that make those elaborate sand
drawings and then just you know yeah
which is fine like I've done so many
there have been projects that I've
worked on for years and then just a
month or two before launching I went
yeah chucked it and it's fine because I
was just doing it I was enjoying it the
whole way like I was it wasn't a goal
it's a didn't launch so what you know
like you know it won't mean anything in
50 years well so what if you enjoyed
doing it
so unless so let me turn it back at you
why what is your thought behind
answering or asking that question so I
think it's twofold the first one is I
think many people don't get to do what
they want to do in life and by asking
what is the meaning of life how can I
find meaning and purpose in my daily
yearly decade Li existence they're
hoping that someone will prescribe them
the steps to get away from doing the
things they don't want to do and move
toward doing the things they do and the
second thing which I've been thinking
about a lot recently to do with this
question is I think a big part of it is
a repackaging of a fear of death I think
humans don't like the idea of dying
unless you've absolutely taken the red
pill on stoic philosophy or free well
whatever it might be there is an innate
fear in dying and previously we might
have had that serviced by religion
previously we might have had that
serviced by a belief in an afterlife or
a higher power or whatever it might be
and now as we have an increasingly
secular society I think people are
trying to find a meaning in their
existence right now which is so great
that it justifies the fact that one day
it's all going to end hmm how's that as
an answer thank you that helps I think
that might be a I genuinely do I did a
podcast a couple of years ago with a guy
who was talking about how he thought
happiness people search for happiness
this proliferation of how to be happy 10
5 steps for your fulfilled life he was
adamant that it was just people fearing
death and then run away from it and I
upon reflection I can see more and more
of that now
yeah you know it's funny I consider my
written output well let's just say any
of this out but I mean you know this
conversation is going to be recorded and
kept around I definitely thinking of all
of this stuff in terms of like after
death you know like I think this is my
legacy I'm leaving all this stuff that
I've written um
Darren brown in the book called happy
did you read that I did I actually got
to see him speak about it a couple of
weeks ago in London as well it's great
oh wow I wish I wouldn't know about that
um I'm a massive fan of his I just shoot
I would whenever people do that
fictional kind of you know if you could
have any person ever in history living
or dead we had a dinner party who would
it be tomatoes Darren brown no need for
Jesus or Buddha or whatever it no just
give me Darren Ghandi just just Darren
brown um so near the end of his book
called happy he had a such a wonderful
tiny point in passing where he said that
your thought patterns are your
personality like this is the way you
think is your personality and you
sharing your thoughts and your
personality with your loved ones or even
sharing them publicly like this carries
on after you die so therefore like that
is the that life after death is your
personality carries on after you're dead
that's you know it's always funny to me
when I say like George Harrison from the
Beatles dies or somebody like that or
Ray Charles and people go oh oh god
that's so sad you know David Bowie
something that I think really oh were
you waiting for David Bowie's next album
have you bought all of his albums in the
last 20 years no it's like well then
he's not dead to you like you're
enjoying what he did in 1972 so you can
carry on enjoying that like David Bowie
is not dead
David Bowie is very much alive the same
thing with a lot of these like famous
musicians that were legends is you
weren't buying their current output
anyway you weren't a dear friend of
theirs they weren't stopping over at
your house next week for dinner so what
they put out there in the world is
completely alive for you like that is
the only version of them that you get
and so yeah I think of this creative
output um as quite eternal at least last
incredible generation yeah it definitely
it definitely is the people that we
leave behind the effect that we have on
them the content we put out you know to
your hell yeah or no concept you know
like how many people is that touched how
many people just as much as you don't
want them to use it as a heuristic
that they are so we need to accept that
and you know at the very beginning of
the call you asked or you mentioned my
hyper simple website part of that is
because I'm expecting this website to go
on a hundred years so who knows what
holographic devices beamed into people's
retinas or implanted in their brains
like websites will be used on in the
Year 2300 but I expect that my site will
be around and so I think people are
using WordPress and current plugins
filled with Google Analytics and
JavaScript [ __ ] is very very
short-sighted like my site is completely
ready that if I were to die tomorrow
this site is going to keep working for a
couple hundred years because it is just
plain HTML and text with absolutely no
contemporary tooling that will expire
and that's very much on purpose like
everything I make my site by hand I
don't use any frameworks I don't use any
software I just type every HTML and
byline by hand so when you asked like
hey it was funny because you even put
the question like you know you said
something like removing everything or
stripping it down but actually it's the
opposite
since I'm open up a blank text document
to create a web page it's a matter of
like why would I take hours of time to
type you know loads of
unnecessary div tags and JavaScript
includes unless it was absolutely
necessary that's too much typing it's
unnecessary so no I just don't put in
anything that isn't needed but a lot of
that's because I'm I'm making a site
that's intended to be around for at
least 100 years that's hardcore I like I
really really like that I was going to
ask actually what code your site was
written in I thought I'd seen something
to do with russ berrie oh I have no idea
no it's you think Ruby um I do use the
Ruby programming language for a little
bit of automation but it just helps me
out put static plain HTML pages with
nothing it originally do your book
summary in was it plain text like a
notepad file or something like the most
hard-core text version that you're gonna
get like it doesn't matter what happens
in future it's always gonna be future
proofed oh dude I do basically I only
use two programs on the computer I use
vim which is a plain like a raw
programmers plain text editor which is
like notepad and like it just does
nothing it doesn't do bold print or
anything like that it does no fonts it
just it's just plain text which is yeah
it's eternal like you know civilizations
on Saturn's moons will be able to read
plain text files I don't think they'll
be able to run you know WordPress 7.2
necessarily but plain text files yes and
and then I use Firefox and that's it
that's like I basically just do
everything all day long in them just a
plain text editor I don't I refuse to
use any I don't do any yeah I don't do
any I don't use the cloud for anything I
do nothing online I don't use Google
Docs I in fact actually prefer working
offline I I kind of do this a funny
little nerdy work habit of mine is about
two hours before I go to sleep I
completely power down my broadband modem
I just go over the wall and I click off
that you know our British power switch
on the wall I just go and like shuts off
the internet so I am now not connected
to the world I hold down both buttons on
the phone so it powers off completely
and so now I'm kind of like in a dark
house with no connection to the world
and that's how I spend the first I mean
the last two hours of every day um I may
continue writing but it's completely
offline and then same thing when I wake
up in the morning I spend like the first
four or five hours of the day completely
offline I don't turn on the internet
usually until noon or so when I've
gotten in a few good hours of writing
and working in programming is that just
to give you time to focus or is this
something most symbolic about that do
you like being off great in that sort of
a way both um I find there's a wonderful
relief peace and relief when I know that
there's no way to contact me you know
like my phone is off the internet is all
off I mean you know I like the fact it's
like if there was a real emergency like
somebody would come banging on my door
you know but I like being unreachable
it's it's a different thing when you're
sitting there focusing on work knowing
that a little part of your brain knows
that there are alerts happening or at
any point you could just grab your phone
and hit Reddit or whatever your fix is
and I like that thing of just not being
able to I'm the kind of guy that I don't
keep cookies in the house you know like
I can't like have a box of cookies and
then just not eat them so it's better
for me just not have the cookies it's
better for me to just completely shut
off the internet and my brain kind of
just goes like that's not an option I
really like that so yeah I work usually
offline plain text files etc yeah
yeah I couldn't agree more one of the
best lifestyle changes I've made over
the last few years has been charging my
phone outside of my bedroom so I mean oh
hell yeah no electronics allowed in the
bedroom
it's so unsexy it isn't that's yeah it
isn't sexy and I found as soon as I did
it I start going to sleep and previously
I remember the old me who when he
couldn't sleep for 15 minutes would just
roll over and go on YouTube which
obvious rate extends the time
right you're going to sleep by hours
because you're just scrolling there's
endless cat video portal um and by
putting it outside of the room it's the
same as that right it's just it's not
there it's no longer an option it's
like it doesn't exist yeah yet to me I
yeah
I literally ban electronics from the
bedroom there's nothing there there is a
little uh a clock by the bed just a
clock it's one of those you know a
little five-pound clocks it just does
nothing but show you the time and that's
it
no phones allowed in the bedroom is it
firelight is it just candles like it
like you know like an old man I wish
that would be great yeah I do have a
candle in the bedroom but you know it's
some actually you know it's kind of cool
is that my kid is now eight and he's
been kind of raised this way so he's not
an iPad addict like a lot of kids his
age are he he actually scoffs at video
games he had a friend two years ago that
um its next door neighbor he was like
it's one of his best friends ever and
this kid's dad was always in the
basement playing fortnight or something
for just hours and was like a completely
absent dad was just completely not there
for the kid was just like grumpy because
all he wanted to be doing was playing
video games and he would just never play
with his kids and so it was so
interesting that my son saw that and not
just noted it but mentioned it to me
like a few different times like how sad
it was and so one time we were playing
just the little word game of opposites
you know what what's the opposite of of
music what's the opposite of a cloud oh
you wanna know my favorite answer yeah
sure wait first take a guess what do you
think is the opposite of music silence
now because silence is part of music
it's an important part what else could
be singing oh okay um my favorite answer
the opposite of music is business these
are the kind of Thunder answers right
see this is that was a fun example of
like you have your first and second you
know that that's like the slow thinking
yeah it's like this idea of like there's
a word game we kept playing so the OP
music his business that's an idea that
didn't come until like a week after
trying to answer the question that was
my favorite answer as I go that's good
anyway I asked my son what is the
opposite of parenting or what is a
feeling of being a dad that's he yeah
he's I think he brought it he said
what's the opposite of being a dad I'm
saying being a mom did you know and his
answer was the winner it was playing
video games because yeah he just has
such a negative association with
watching his friends dad just play video
games instead of being there for his kid
like anyway so point is yeah we have a
household that is very offline no no let
me take that back
not very often it's part-time offline
and I really like that it's not the
primary thing like there's no TV in the
house it's not like the house isn't
arranged around a television like most
are yeah anyway that's a self-aware kid
that you've got there
Derek is resound really really cool
thank you um I want to touch on
excellence for a minute as I mentioned
it as one of my core values and it's
something that we've been talking about
a little bit recently and I wondered how
you how you balance between wanting the
best workout of yourself wanting to
produce something which you're proud of
and connects with other people and is a
a high representation of your cumulative
skills and talents and stuff with also
giving yourself sufficient of a break
and I wondered what what your thoughts
were on excellence something that I see
as a core value to my life but I
wondered what your thoughts were right
hmm well let's look at the micro example
of procrastination all right like if you
look at why people procrastinate it's
usually if you're facing something
difficult it's easier to retreat into
the safe thing like surfing the winter
Weber playing video games instead of
uncomfortably facing what needs to be
done so the way to stop procrastination
is to catch your
doing it to deliberately interrupt it
um and then go back to doing what you
need what doing what you know you needs
to do no matter how unpleasant it is and
then I think it always gets easier after
you begin so when I think of excellence
I think of like a life-sized version of
that like if there's something you've
always wanted to do you need to stop
wasting time and do it um like I said
earlier like what what you want now
versus what you want most um if you
write out your bucket list you know like
the things you want to do before you die
I'll bet you could do almost all of them
in a few months you know most of them in
just a few weeks it's usually like
people's bucket lists or like places
they want to go and some things they
want to do and I think well you know you
if you just took a couple months off
work you could do it 2/3 of that list
right now be done by next month it's
just a matter of doing them instead of
doing other things like watching shows
surfing the web playing video games
they're just sitting around on couches
hanging out tasting the local beer it's
like it's there these things that we do
I'm sorry I'm kind of answering your
your excellence questions in a way of
like well what's the opposite of
excellence procrastination like the
opposite of excellence is giving in to I
don't wanna call it procrastination but
that that same thing that triggers
procrastination which is usually like
you're facing the uncomfortable thing
that you know you need to do and so you
do the easier relief thing instead
people who choose the easy path in life
don't ever get excellence and anything
like excellence is usually choosing the
more difficult path which gives the
greater rewards it's doing what you know
you need to do even if you don't feel
like it I mean my definition of
excellence is tainted by the fact that
you know that was
music for twenty formative years of my
life you know so I think in terms of
like being an excellent performer being
an excellent writer I think an excellent
producer whatever so you might have a
different definition of being a an
excellent gentleman or something like
that definitely could be I know I mean I
mean that somebody listening to this
could have a different definition where
maybe excellence to them is just
excellence in their composure every day
maybe it isn't something you need to
practice for 20 years maybe it can
actually just be in in the moment like
you could just decide right now today to
like from this moment on to be excellent
and you can achieve that you know by
just um not giving in to your temper or
stopping drinking or whatever it may be
so um yeah I think it's um precision is
the word that I like to associate with
excellence huh
why precision because precision for me
is doing the thing that you said that
you were going to do or doing the thing
that you mean to do not doing another
thing it's one of the reasons why I like
yourself as a speaker why I like ben
shapiro and some harris as a speaker
because the speech is very precise the
number of words that i used other number
of words and needed i linked back to
what you said earlier on about the way
that people make choices and a kind of
life they have does that mean that
everyone will be familiar with which is
easy choices hard life hard choice right
easy life and i think about that another
thing i read a really interesting
article from taylor pearson on
procrastination and one of the things
that he came up with as he says
procrastination exists because people
have a fear of failure they're concerned
that they may be not good enough or that
they don't have the skills that required
i certainly think there's an element
that he didn't touch on in this bit
which is to do with it it's just
difficult there's some inertia to get
over i have to do hard and there's
something easier flowing around the
cookie jar the the social media mmm fix
and he has this beautiful quote where he
says um interestingly sometimes we
procrastinate to ensure that we
inoculate ourselves from public failure
but the interesting thing is by
procrastinating we do inoculate
ourselves from public failure by
assuring ourselves of private failure
hmm
I love that I love the the reframing of
that I take a look like if you do not do
this thing it doesn't matter whether you
think you would or would not fail
because you're guaranteeing the fact
that you will by not starting it right
hmm I thought that was really powerful
model is it an interesting way to to
loop it back around but look there yeah
I'm conscious to the fact that I'm
taking up your time and it's an evening
I've got I got two questions that one
wants okay before we finish if that's
okay first one what have you changed
your mind about recently the a lot of
the things that I said were core values
or actually pretty new to me maybe
that's why they came to mind first when
you asked because I think they're the
most interesting because they're the
newest to my brain the stuff that's been
in my piano value system for thirty
years they just take for granted and I
probably don't even know it's there
anymore
um but acknowledging nuance looking for
not deliberately making sure you're not
oversimplifying even though I write
succinctly because I think it's
considerate
I don't think truth is succinct I think
truth is very nuanced
memorable sound bites are succinct quips
and aphorisms are succinct helping an
idea carry further um you know sickness
is good to carry ideas it makes it good
you know what would he call it nature
whether those seeds that have like um
little barbs on them like dandelions
thank you yeah dandelion sir or birds so
succinct honest is a good tool to help
ideas spread and carry but succinct Ness
is almost the opposite of truth because
yeah you can make catchy slogans that
make people go wow that's good but it's
just it's one little ingredient in the
truth the truth of things I think is
often very nuanced it's like well in in
these situations if you're in that stage
in your life and for the kind of person
you are the kind of things you want well
then this is true but if in another day
you know in the morning or you know last
year or if you were a little bit of
different person
via for your sister that is not true but
for your brother it is you know this age
you're at and for what you want in life
but is in fact if you were to quit your
job tomorrow then suddenly that would no
longer be true when in fact it's like
all of these but that doesn't tweet well
so that's that's pretty new for me like
this constant acknowledgement of the
nuance of things to get it the truth I
can actually talk about this thing
because I'm not going to name names I
have a dear friend who's been with the
same guy for years but complaining about
him for years
often calling me any kind of like what
should I do
should I leave him should I stay what's
gonna this and finally I thought was
this kind of new focus on nuance we
realized like I think she's actually
happy being one foot out the door
like that's we don't need to
oversimplify it into an either/or should
I stay or should I go now um it's the
the truth is
she's happiest with this one foot out
the door feeling and she doesn't need to
oversimplify that into inner out hmm
this is one Nana that's all right that
example just actually came up yesterday
so that's that's on my mind I really
like it I meant to bring this up earlier
on while I was podcasting with George
McGill last year the highest played ever
modern wisdom episode that we've doing
about mental models he talked about the
barbell strategy which is where you
don't just have black or white thinking
you have black and white thinking and
you push yourself to the end you're able
to do incredible deep work but then also
be very social when you need to turn
that on you are able to use the succinct
side of things but you're also able to
understand the nuance as well at the
complete opposite end of the scale
there's a another point on that that I
just have to bring up which is I love
aphorisms and I think that guys like
Noelle who are able to distill down
incredible wisdom into what 160
characters or whatever is it's just it's
a skill that I absolutely do not have
and wildly envious I think it's really
cool but you the reason that you created
your directives was because you realized
that most of what a book is is getting
people to believe and trust the author
and provide sufficient context that they
believe the instruction that they're
then given but if people were to
sufficiently trust whoever is it was
giving it to them the directive can be
the leanest takeaway from that
particular book and the equivalent is
when you see on Instagram you scroll
through Instagram and there's someone's
put up a quote you know Senecas life's
work distilled down into a single
sentence but the context isn't there you
just scrolling past Booty picture booty
picture funny dog video after aphorism
of Senecas life booty picture booty pit
you know I mean that there's no contact
there's no buy-in you're not in the
right frame of mind you haven't had that
I trust Seneca I know who he is that a
like and I think you're right
I think you are corrector there's
there's um the nuance and the
understanding of that I think it all
ties together
cool final question final question you
have brought up today a couple of
different projects that you're working
on some books that will be released in
the future have you got is it within a
year is it within six months is it
within a decade
can we give the people that are
listening they're fans of yours any idea
and when they can expect this new piece
of work from you oh there's three I
finished my next book two years ago
I finished my second book one year ago
and I'm finishing my third book now but
the thing is I nerd it out on
self-publishing my first big book called
anything you want was published by well
first by Seth Godin but then he sold his
little publishing imprint to penguin so
then penguin re-released it so it's you
know it's on a major publishing company
but I didn't actually like that
experience um
why I didn't like that I didn't fully
own the rights to my own book and so I
get you know I got contacted like he was
just one core example sorry you asked me
it kind of like a no no I want I want
this one said we want the new ones we're
here so once there were two or three
different times when I got contacted by
people that were putting on a conference
that wanted to buy like 750 copies for
all of their attendees and I said great
that's amazing I would love to do that
and they say okay can how do we do they
come and get like a quantity discount
for 750 copies and I have to go ask
penguin hey penguin hello my reference I
was in sales yeah how can we do that and
they went oh well you just have to tell
them to buy it at Amazon like there's no
way to buy seven that you can't order it
from us we're not a retailer and you
know and they said oh man like that's
that sucks too like I want this person
to have $700 each would be fine you know
like just how cool that they're gonna
give and so to have to tell this guy
like yeah just go to Amazon and type 750
in the quantity I was like man this
sucks like I I want to be able to do the
right thing but I don't even own the
rights to you know and
when has the rights I mean I wrote that
book for Seth Godin and then you know
that's what happens um
so even though my rep at penguin loves
me and she's wonderful and she's great
and I like her as a person I just didn't
like the experience I have I don't need
the the ego gratification of being on a
major publisher so I just really decided
to self-publish to keep control which
kind of reminds me of way back when I
started CD Baby in like the mid 90s like
the internet was just kind of getting
started there was that cool kind of
do-it-yourself pseudo punky kind of
ethic about like sticking it to the man
like I you know [ __ ] the major record
labels man I'm gonna do this myself like
I'm not signing away my rights to some
label but here we are
20-something years later and everybody's
like selling their soul to Amazon just
everything like you know you said
earlier you know here's how to do the
Google AdWords to increase your business
just like everything's trying to please
the man the man is now like Facebook
Google Amazon - whatever Instagram and
everybody's just trying to please the
man it reminds me of that kind of pre
internet thing where everybody was
selling their soul to the major record
labels and hopes of getting rich and I
appreciated that kind of given it all
the finger kind of spirit knowing that
you're probably gonna sell less by
choosing to be independent but [ __ ] yeah
it felt so much better point is I nerd
it out on not just self-publishing but
like self printing self layout like I
you know how I told you I do everything
in my plain text editor called them yeah
well do you think I did the book design
layout in Adobe InDesign no [ __ ] Adobe I
didn't [ __ ] plain text like software
called latex which you can like do book
design in like as a programmer in plain
text I'm like [ __ ] went hardcore on
that and I and I'm just building my own
store on my own site because [ __ ] Amazon
I don't want to sell my book on Amazon I
will eventually and it's just like you
know what I understand that I'm choosing
to sell less by doing this but goddamn
it feel
better it's like so much more fun each
books worth a hundred of what the one
would have been before right because you
crafted the thing out of ancient
technology in a programming language
that no one it seems since the 1800s
yeah exactly it's funny you know we talk
about rationality walking you and I
don't but people talk about rationality
and yeah there are things where you
could say that this is a rationally
unwise choice but emotions matter and
the way that something feels is a big
reason why we do anything in fact you
know if you want to get meta meta meta
the reason that people like to be
rational is because it feels better
right and yeah there so anyway sorry I
was answering your question about when
are these books coming out well you end
up any day now that we understand why
they're not here yet yes because I heard
it out on the self-publishing and the
self printing in ooh and lastly I
decided to print hardcover books for the
emotional reason that I found that
knowing that I was going to be printing
hardcover books even though like I'm a
total tree hugger I don't want to waste
a single sheet of paper ever I thought
well damn if these think if I'm gonna be
cutting down trees like really every
sentence has to be worth cutting down a
tree now and it made me a better writer
knowing that I was going to print
hardcover hyung books up the stakes of
the right yes yeah and so um anyway it's
all just about tone and I'm putting the
I was actually this morning I was
programming the store on my site with
the you know the whole put your thing
into a card and then by doing it all
myself I get to do some fun nerdy things
like I can do custom dedications and
things that you know people who sell
their book on Amazon can't do so
everybody that orders the book for me
can ask it to be custom dedicated to
them and the server will create a custom
dedicated book for you
and I'm gonna see if I can do that with
the audiobook too so everybody who buys
the audiobook it gets a custom little
like you know hey Chris
it's Derek this book's removed I mean
you know again [ __ ] Amazon they can't do
that you're right you're right
org slash podcasts and then such
audiobooks slash books such everything
and exactly and then it can be civis
baby anyway so anybody who anybody who
wants my stuff you could probably tell
cuz you know you and I have emailed a
bunch I actually enjoy taking a few
minutes a day to answer all my emails I
really like hearing from strangers I
actually really like it when people
introduce themselves I like it when
somebody's like you know
I'm a guitar technician in Arizona or
I'm a whatever a dentist in Estonia I
just really like hearing what people
around the world are doing and and all
that kind of stuff so I really like it
when people introduce themselves and
feel free to email me and ask me a
question and if you go to San Fran work
my email address is out there in the
public and you can email me and ask me
anything and I always reply cool that's
certainly cooler than just saying I'll
head to my Twitter it's I email me and I
might get back to you if I - am I in -
no you know Twitter that's still like a
corporate middleman like you know
actually I'm really thankful that I got
online in 1994 because I went through
that first dot-com boom and crash where
a lot of companies that people were
totally dependent on like MySpace like
every musician was 100% dependent on
their MySpace page to manage all of
their fan lists all of their music and
their releases and their announcements
and their gigs were all done through
their MySpace page and then myspace
disappears I was like so I think I just
have this healthy distrust of any
corporate middleman I think they're
always about to go belly up any day so
um no I would never tell people to like
you know the Twitter was their way to
reach me because I don't trust that
they'll be around tomorrow
think that if you've got plain text
files as the future proofed version of
writing things down I think you've got
email lists as the most likely to
survive a nuclear apocalypse exactly
contact yeah because it's an open
standard and it's like it's on
commercial I really like those
uncommercial media forms like right so
so paper books have no you know
advertisements in them no Amazon's not
tracking what you highlight in a paper
book email yeah open technology I love
that kind of stuff anyway nerd nerd nerd
we were saying goodbyes so baby didn't
keep taking tangent it's been such a
pleasure thank you so much to the people
that are listening anything that we have
spoken about will be linked in the show
notes below along with Derek's website
where you can go on and hassle them by
your email and not is Twitter because
[ __ ] Twitter there won't be a link to
Adobe After Effects in there either
because photos over to Derek man thank
you so much for your time I really
appreciated thanks Chris it's a fun
conversation
[Music]